les demandes des consommateurs envers
les agriculteurs sont de plus en plus
élevés mais ces exigences ont un coût
que nous ne sommes pas toujours prêts à
défrayer
l'exemple du lait bio est révélateur en
régie biologique non seulement l'accès
au pâturage est obligatoire mais si les
vaches sont en stabulation entravée en
hiver elles peuvent avoir accès à une
aire d'exercice au moins deux fois par
semaine ils sont ne sont que
quelques-unes des exigences pour obtenir
la certification biologique
au final le lait bio coûtent presque le
double du lait conventionnel
or même si leurs produits correspondent
aux valeurs de bien des consommateurs au
québec les producteurs de lait bio sont
confrontés à un ralentissement de la
demande depuis quelques années jusqu'ici
en 2022 près de 20 % du lait produit
selon les normes biologiques a dû être
vendus comme du lait conventionnel ce
qui représente un manque à gagner pour
les producteurs bio certains
agriculteurs qui ont fait la transition
au cours des dernières années sont
aujourd'hui incapables de vendre leur
lait comme du bio et de bénéficier de la
prime il pourrait toutefois obtenir
temporairement le soutien financier de
leurs confrères conventionnelle une
proposition en ce sens doit être soumise
au vote des producteurs de lait du
québec en avril ailleurs dans le monde
différentes approches en appui au
secteur bio existent notamment via un
seuil minimum d'aliments biologiques
dans les cafétérias des écoles garderies
et hôpitaux
[Musique]